the jurgen experience
you know functional strength exercises
that's a real weight right joe
ah i think so yeah everybody made fun of
me because of the chris cuomo thing man
yeah i thought it was real i just i'm
being naive i guess but eventually i
looked at i go yeah that is kind of
weird how you can move it around like
that yeah just like a [ __ ]
paperweight so that guy's fire now got
rid of that dude yeah wow wait a weird
for a real weird reason
i mean not weird like ethically i get it
because he helped his brother and his
brother i get i don't know how he helped
his brother like what did he do
his brother was getting they were
people were accusing him of sexual
harassment
and so did he like do research on the
people that
is that what he did i remember reading
he texted someone who like knew of the
situation like what do you got on
someone and
oh that's it i don't know if that's it i
just should use signal yeah yeah
yeah
or call the guy i mean
it's uh he probably didn't think
anything of it he probably did it on
instinct but yeah he's done
what does a guy like that do when you
get fired from somebody i know i thought
that guy was like immune to
everything
well i think cnn is realizing that their
ratings are dog [ __ ] yeah and that
having these
highly polarizing
editorial personalities like stelter and
don lemon and you know michael malus is
[ __ ] hilarious you know what he did
he put up he goes now that chris cuomo's
gone who's the alpha male over at cnn
and he put up a poll and everybody said
to anderson cooper
i think anderson cooper came in first
but it's like these they it's i i
personally maybe maybe this is just my
bias i want
the news i want objective news i want
someone to tell me what are the facts of
what's going on and what's happening i
don't want your ideological slant i
don't want this left-wing propaganda
network which is what cnn's become the
way i look at cnn now is so differently
than the way i looked to see an end of
15 20 years ago yeah i used to look at
them as like this is how i get the news
this is
unbiased professional news they're going
to tell me what's happening in pakistan
and what's happening in you know
mogadishu this these are this is these
are the real journalists that are
telling you the news now i look at them
i go you [ __ ] propagandists like
the right arm of pfizer like what are
you doing yeah you know
it's just uh
i think there's a market for real news
and it's really hard to find that now
it's really hard especially outside of
independent sources yeah
yeah and i guess if you're trying to
even take a balanced approach to things
like are you even gonna be they're gonna
be censored to the point where
you can't even be a news outlet to begin
with right so
you